si loin et si proche sélection
présidentielle de 2027 c'est dans quatre
ans mais certains candidats putatifs ont
déjà un appétit d'ogre c'est le cas
d'Edouard Philippe l'ancien Premier
ministre et chef de file du parti
horizon était de passage hier en
Touraine le maire du Havre a tenu
meeting sur le thème de l'école de
devant 300 personnes et soutiens leur
reportage à Montbazon de Clémence d'OSC
comme un air de campagne présidentielle
à la Guinguette de Montbazon mercredi
soir l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe terminait son escapade en
région Centre par une réunion publique
environ 300 personnes ont fait le
déplacement parmi elles des curieux des
encartés horizons mais aussi pas mal
d'élus du territoire il a une certaine
comment dirais-je il a de la diplomatie
il a de la sagesse c'est déjà énorme
pour gouverner un pays c'est toujours
important que les hauts politiques
s'approchent du terrain parce qu'il y a
des similitudes à faire qui doivent se
croiser simplement
on a des convictions partagées donc
voilà les kilomètres ne font pas peur
quand on pense que c'est pour la bonne
cause partie politique fondée en 2021
horizon compte 28 députés à l'Assemblée
parmi eux Henri alfandary député de la
troisième circonscription
d'Indre-et-Loire il est aussi délégué
départemental du parti
ce sont nos élus tous ceux qui
s'engagent c'est aussi toute la société
civile de sorte de de ne pas échafauder
de grands plans sans être certain que ça
a une réalité concrète donc voir loin et
se baser sur des réalités concrètes
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
aujourd'hui pas d'évocation explicite
d'une candidature d'Édouard Philippe en
2027 mais 30 minutes de discours pour
tenter de rassembler le plus grand
nombre au centre le tout sans oublier le
fil rouge de ses visites du jour
l'éducation tout à l'heure j'ai vu les
maires du de l'ancien canton de mon
trésor
qui m'ont expliqué l'initiative qu'ils
ont pris en matière d'éducation cette
initiative s'appelle terre et Cole elle
est passionnante elle est extraordinaire
et c'est la première fois que je voyais
une initiative de ce type dans un milieu
rural le meeting c'est clôturé par une
Marseillaise puis un énième bain de
foule l'ancien Premier ministre a pris
la poudre d'escampette peu avant 22
heures